Anthony what have you learned about
making money here is an actor in LA as
an actor it's hard and when it's good
it's phenomenal I kind of like almost a
sales job that's based purely on
Commission that when things are going
well you're on top of the world and then
when they're not you're you know crying
under your covers which I don't do but
that old thing calling home wondering
what you're doing with your life every
personality or kind of goes through
those little moments of weakness which
is understandable but it's hard it's
hard but it's also probably the most
rewarding thing and going back to social
media you know people outside of it they
always wonder oh why are all these
actors always posting everything it's
because they're proud of what they're
doing and they've worked hard and they
want to show it their family and friends
and I'm really really behind that it's
it is it's a rewarding experience it's
there's something validating about
getting a check for a performance it is
it's just it's just a cool thing and
that's why I think there's a lot of
happy actors out there that are doing
really well but I always see that on
like booked it and then actors access
yeah but will like retweet it you know
and oh yeah just just yeah people are
proud I get it because sometimes those
moments are few and far between and then
it is and they and the acting world and
kind of entertainment industry in
general is there's a lot of people
working their butts off and they're not
getting a paycheck and that doesn't mean
they're not good at it doesn't mean
they're not working hard doesn't mean
they're not focusing their energy in the
right spot it's just all about sometime
it is about timing is about dumb luck
here or there right place right time and
that's why it's just rewarding in the
end game but yeah it is hard you know
being able to support your life fully as
an actor is a rare thing out here I mean
you have your a-listers that obviously
isn't it they're never gonna have to
think about money again but the other
99.9 percent of us out here aren't don't
have that and it's a constant hustle
moving on to the next thing you know
short memory you did that fantastic got
to find the next big one you think that
once somebody gets to that point of
never having to worry about money
it takes away some of the joy in life
you think there's like this weird hunger
that keeps people fired up I think it
depends for the person but I mean I've
ran into people that it's like you know
go for that old saying of you know once
you start getting paid for something it
loses its artists integrity or that
starving artists like I'm doing it just
to do it and then you get paid for but
then there's also other flip sides like
find something you love and you'll never
feel like you're working it's kind of
that I think it varies from person to
person so far I still love it whether I
get paid or not I'm still putting in the
effort and the work and kind of the
company I keeps the same way
you